May the worst man die
Electric skateboard jousting. The Spring Festival. If you've been watching the previous videos, we've had a Tournament of Champions
Which has come down to four champions myself, Nick
Carmichael and Niko all competing for the right to represent one brand and to give away a free
Subscription to that brand for the rest of 2019 a king Sam will determine two
semifinal rounds, the winners of semi final rounds will go to fight in a final round. And the final round will not end until
one of the Knights is dead. That's right. So even if you fall off your horse
You can still pick up a sword and keep fighting.
My bloodline shall win-nuhhehehe.
My mother and my uncle made me.
It's more like a family,
family. Yes, each ab is a pustule
The first combatant is red.
Your highness. And his opponent will be...
Wait this isn't a neck or chief. What is that? Is this a holy relic?
*Gasps of shock at seeing a holy relic*
No, this is actually our next limited-edition sale! It's an incredible—its made just for the spring tournament of champions.
I think it's so holy that there's only 500 of these that exist on earth.
If you like this, snag one today at corridordigital.store. And his opponent...
The dark blue night, "Patreon"
"Hey, how dare you? Smack me with your gloves? How dare you?" Save it for the tournament.
Each jousting round will be a best of three if you knock your opponent off twice you win.
We got a bunch of bamboo leftover from the prim tech shoot
So we took 12 foot pieces of bamboo put some boxing gloves around the end of them and BAM!
Alright.
Ready and! 3! 2! 1!
*honking*
*Laughing*
I said...
*Agressive honking*
You guys don't need to go slow just because we're recording slow-mo
Getting better every time.
*Starting honks*
Oh!
*Honks yet again*
Oooh!
Come here winner!
Never easy letting down your friends.
He's terrifying. It's like an army with spears.
My strategy is... believe in myself and have faith in what life has given me
Solid thumping, good momentum. No practice rounds. I'm being serious. You will be judged on the merit of your joust
May the worst man die...
Go!
*Honks*
*Thump*
Niko still on!
What an impact. Lady audible! So if Niko wins this next round. He is the semi champion
May the worst man die!
*Thump*
That was intense!
Aw man. You took his helmet off dude! He didn't know what hit him. Yeah, yeah, your nose is bleeding of it
It's just a flesh wound. This is actually going to decide who wins to finally tie back up
I want to see one of these men
Die!
*Sam Screech*
*Honking*
*Slo-mo thump*
The irony taste of blood my mouth that's just enraged me even more...
to face off against Sir Nick the younger. He's about to become Sir Nick the underground
So Niko's stance is pretty
It's pretty unstoppable right now. It's a very very solid stance
So I think I'm gonna take a note out of his book and try to do the double knee plant
Uhhhhh
This is the final joust. The last man standing
will be the one who wins. Ready?
And...
JOUST!
*Honk*
*Thump*
Even if you fall off your horse, you can still pick up a sword and keep fighting.
Sword!
Woah x8
Thumbs up or down?
Thumbs... up, but by technically down,
right that means kill them, down is kill them
*Niko dying as Sam cackles*
Ah, That's how it was the only in the olden days, down was actually kill him.
You rightfully won the joust and the duel.
So you are the champion.
Yes, dude, do I get hanging chains?
As many as you want, endless. Big chain we'll hook you up
I will choose one lucky person to get a year of Expressvpn
Free
Before we find out who the winner is of this Expressvpn reward with Nick
I wanted to take a moment and tell you guys about our brand new shirts. That's right. We only made
500 of these that's five zero zero and they're going and they're on sale right now at corridor digital dot store
In fact by the time you get there
There's certainly gonna be less than 500. So head on over there if you like it.
Show your friends how much you love...
D&D or just this great design and remember we had this thing created
Because the Spring Festival was coming up and we wanted to do something cool, something special
To commemorate and mark that moment you guys like what we do on this channel definitely consider supporting us by picking up a t-shirt
because
the money goes right back into these videos, so.
Niko, we're waiting for them to go to the store There's only 500 of these
Will probably sell out the first two days. They always do especially if you like a average size like medium, right?
You want it, go now. Wait another 5 seconds.
Okay,  any minute now, let's tell them, let's tell them.
Alright, so we're gonna go through the comments here
We're gonna see which comment really captures the spirit of the Spring Festival
You had to have expressvpn as a service or gotten it's because of this video and made a comment in this video
We're gonna be looking for somebody that says that in the comments.
All right. So we're getting a lot of road worker videos... Obviously cause,  comments on the *in unison* yeah
Pothole warfare, like to cook soup in potholes to help— I mean that's not healthy. Yeah
I just want to say that your ads are epic. Okay, I love free expressvpn but *incoherant* Okay.
I, a European really need to be vpn for my memes,  now that article 13 has been approved. That kind of hits me right here
Here we go. Here's one guy. I signed up to expressvpn because of this video. Okay, Okay. I want to:
I want to use—see he's not using it. There's another one. I actually use expressvpn in China
Expressvpn cord life yo, there was no statement of I have the service, right? I use it. So, disqualified. Sorry. Oh, okay
I actually use expressvpn in China so I can play games and use discord. It's great
And it has only stopped working a few times over a year during large VPN crackdowns. I think this guy might please give me expressvpn
I have subscribed
That doesn't cut it, but thank you for your subscription
A lot of people are just asking for the VPN but not stating that they have it. Alright, there's I use expressvpn
I sign up to expressvpn you can because of this video and I use Expressvpn in China and Expressvpn for life.
Yo, who's the best we're gonna go with one loose lambs from China?
may your memes and this port be uninterrupted from now on at least for the end of the year because buddy
You got expressvpn all year long who lose lab son. Oh, yeah, and uh,
Case you've forgotten you should turn on the notifications and subscribe because most of you aren't even subscribed and that sad